Speaker 1: Many different right wing media outlets
and right wing elected officials slamming Ron
DeSantis decision to announce his presidential
campaign on Twitter. One such critique or ridicule
came from Fox and Friends. Fox and friends with
a What the heck is Twitter? Spacey's moment
ridiculing DeSantis for his choice here.
Speaker 2: Hey, Lucas. So
he's going to make the big announcement
with Elon Musk at 6:00 tonight on Twitter
spaces, right? What the heck is Twitter spaces?
Speaker 1: I wish I knew.
Speaker 2: More about him, but.
Speaker 3: I think he's trying
to make it sound like a video.
Speaker 2: Function. Yeah, right.
Speaker 3: Yeah. There's a pipeline somewhere
streaming and some podcasts and that kind of
thing. I think it's fascinating that they're using
social media as a way to announce a presidency.
Speaker 1: Yes, it's all very fascinating. So,
listen, there's people wrote to me and said,
you know, David, it's weird because yesterday
morning, Fox and Friends was just gushing about
how great Tim Scott is and now they're making
fun of Ron DeSantis. What are the explanations?
There's two primary interpretations of this. One
interpretation is that Fox sees DeSantis as the
only guy that might defeat Trump. So they attack
him and praise Tim Scott, who doesn't have a shot,
all in reality, in service to helping Trump.
You attack the only guy that might beat Trump.
You kind of pretend to prop up guys that have no
shot like Tim Scott, and it just keeps Trump at
the front. That's one interpretation of what Fox,
Fox and Friends is doing. Second interpretation
is they genuinely want someone other than
Trump. But for whatever reason, the brass
at Fox News has decided DeSantis is not the guy
we want. So we're going to make fun of DeSantis
and praise Tim Scott. We absolutely have no idea
at this point in time. Fox News's priority really
is maintain access to those in power, and that
is going to be their primary motivation. We will
see in the next couple of weeks how Fox News
his perspective on the primary solidifies.